throw it out drop it throw the gun
[Applause]
drop the gun try don't try to get out
drop the gun body camera video
surveillance footage and 9-1-1 calls
released by the phoenix police
department detailed the timeline of an
officer-involved shooting i need an
officer assistant
with this person who
pointed his firearm at me it all started
with a 911 july 15 a security guard
stationed off the 117 freeway in phoenix
reported an aggravated assault saying a
man banned from the property pointed a
gun at him and this person pointed a gun
to you or what did they point at you
yeah he pointed his um
pistol at me the suspect then walked to
a nearby parking lot where he met up
with someone he knew who was driving a
u-haul the reference that 245 call they
were saying that he possibly pointed the
gun again and now at a u-haul driver
officials say the suspect then
whipped the man in the parking lot twice
before running inside the hotel he's
running through the north stairwell
anything on north carolina running the
north stairwell phoenix police responded
to the hotel where the suspect evaded
arrest
will be advised done in his right hand
point down the hallway gun in right hand
corners down the hallway body camera
footage shows what happened as officers
attempted to arrest the suspect first
they used an object that shoots out foam
batons
[Applause]
when that didn't stop the suspect an
officer fired his weapon
hotel surveillance video shows the
suspect hiding in a stairwell holding a
gun in his right hand and a cell phone
and backpack in his left hand the
suspect then opens the door and
allegedly points the gun at officers in
the hallway that's when the officer
fired his weapon no one was injured in
the shooting after that the suspect ran
off to a hotel laundry room and tried to
hide from officers in a dryer after that
he pointed the gun at his own head throw
it out drop it throw the gun
[Applause]
out drop the gun try don't try to get
out drop the gun just keep crawling out
keep crawling out
keep coming
keep coming
no don't
don't reach back additional body cam
footage shows officers fire stun bags at
the suspect
after that the suspect finally complies
and is taken into custody he was later
treated at a nearby hospital for
injuries from the projectiles he was
later released and booked into the
maricopa county jail from here an
internal and criminal investigation into
the officer-involved shooting is being
conducted it will be reviewed by the
maricopa county attorney's office the
officer involved in the shooting is a
six-year veteran of the department for
the latest developments in this case and
all things true crime stay with long
crime network i'm sierra gillespie